All right.
We'll get started. It's 3:01,
almost. So thank you for joining us on this, what's a
beautiful day outside, but we also have a beautiful day of science
inside.
And we have a great session for you focusing on liquid biopsy
frontiers.
It's meant to capture
innovative approaches for liquid biopsy,
and we have a fantastic session. I want to introduce you along
with my co-chair, Dr. Ajay Goel from City of Hope.
My name's Scott Bratman. I'm at Princess Margaret Cancer Center and University of
Toronto.
Here are my disclosures.
And so I've added the agenda for you here just
to preview the session. You see that we have seven
talks from representing a range of
institutions and topics.
Our talks really run the gamut across
the
cancer continuum, as well as the types of
methodologies employed for liquid biopsy.
So just to provide a couple slides for context.
We know that liquid biopsy approaches are widely
employed now across the cancer continuum,
starting at early detection and screening
methodologies through molecular residual disease in
localized cancers,
as we heard in the plenary yesterday.
But also with broad utility that's been demonstrated across metastatic
cancers. And today we're going to hear some nice
examples of where this utility could be expanded in the future
through novel methods.
So broadly speaking, the first several talks will be focused
on this advanced cancer setting,
where utility is being explored across
therapy guidance,
treatment selection, and monitoring of resistance mechanisms.
And then the
last two talks will shift earlier in the cancer
continuum into the screening and methodologies that
may enable improved early detection and screening approaches.
I also mentioned that there will be a range of analytes explored, and
that already in the clinic, we have circulating tumor DNA for certain
indications as well as circulating tumor cells.
But we'll also hear about some novel types of analytes here,
including red blood cells,
and including the detection, quantification, and
characterization of these novel analytes.
And so again, the breakdown of the talks
according to this axis is summarized here,
where we'll have a number of talks focusing on ctDNA,
both with canonical mutation-based
approaches as well as epigenetic markers.
But also a number of talks focusing on cells, both
classic circulating tumor cell markers as well as novel
cell markers based in the red blood cell pellet.
So with that as a brief overview of the talk,
I again encourage you to interact in this session,
and enjoy the innovative science that helps to highlight liquid
biopsy as a dynamic precision oncology platform,
and new innovative diagnostic tools that hopefully will
continue to transform cancer management.
So with that,
please
if we can pull up the initial slides.
And our first presentation is Dr. William Bowers from Johns
Hopkins University. Please
come on up and watch the step here.
You might not need it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good afternoon. My name is William Bowers.
I am a undergraduate student and university undergraduate research fellow
at Johns Hopkins University. On behalf of my peers in the
molecular oncology lab at the Sidney Kimmel Comprehensive Cancer Center,
I'm delighted to present to you our study entitled "Serial Plasma
Comprehensive Genomic Profiling Detects Therapy Resistance and Guides
Management of Metastatic Non-Small Cell Lung Cancer."
I have no financial disclosures.
Comprehensive genomic profiling of non-small cell lung cancer tumors has
unraveled oncogene dependencies and therapeutic vulnerabilities that have been
translated into new treatment strategies with a clear survival
benefit. To this end, plasma comprehensive genomic
profiling offers a minimally invasive, cost-effective, and rapid
turnaround approach to match patients to genotype-targeted therapies,
monitor response to therapy, and capture drivers of therapy resistance,
enabling treatment optimization.
But still, the precise clinical utility of serial
PCGP remains insufficiently studied outside of
controlled trials in real-world institutional cohorts.
Using EGFR-driven non-small cell lung cancer as a representative
example, retrospective liquid biopsy analyses were used to
evaluate mechanisms of acquired resistance to osimertnib in the FLORA
trial, with osimertnib representing
the-Standard treatment recommended
care as first-line therapy in patients with non-small cell lung cancer harboring
canonical EGFR activating alterations.
And the most commonly detected mechanism of resistance was MET amplification,
followed by secondary EGFR alterations.
And in addition to patients with single acquired resistance mechanisms, several
patients had multiple resistance mechanisms, including co-mutations in genes
involved in cancer hallmarks such as cell cycle control and in the MAP kinase
pathway. And this resistance landscape differs from that associated with
first and second generation EGFR TKIs, which is really driven
by EGFR T790M alterations, and is followed
secondarily by MET amplification, and by CDK6
amplification as well. And so this study, and
others jointly indicate that mechanisms of acquired resistance
to genotype-targeted therapies in non-small cell lung cancer are driven by the
selective pressure of TKIs, which can vary based on the specific
drug and how these drugs are sequenced.
And so our main goal was to understand the clinical utility of serial
PCGP in a real-world institutional cohort for informing
precision oncology interventions and for characterizing drivers of therapy
resistance based on the targeted therapy used and whether it was used as
first-line or later-line treatment.
To that end, we conducted a retrospective study of 718 patients with
non-small cell lung cancer who had at least one instance of liquid
biopsy and were managed at our institution between 2015 and
2022.
The detailed cohort characteristics are shown in the table on the right, and
among 214 patients with EGFR mutant non-small cell lung cancer,
42% were administered first-line osimertnib, and the remaining 58% were
treated with a first or second-generation EGFR TKI, which really
represents the evolving treatment landscape during the study duration.
We leveraged standard workflows belonging to the Johns Hopkins Precision
Medicine Analytics Platform and Lung Cancer Precision Medicine Center of
Excellence, which jointly enabled multi-source data
integration for thoracic cancer cohorts within a precision oncology
framework.
Variant calls from fixed gene panel hybrid capture next-generation sequencing
assays, Guardant 360 and Guardant 360X, were programmatically
retrieved, and these assays were performed as part of standard of care management.
We also programmatically retrieved tissue next-generation sequencing data, which
comprised a range of CLIA-approved assays, again, used for routine
comprehensive genomic profiling in the clinical setting.
Genomic alterations were characterized based on the AMP-ASCO-CAP joint
guidelines, and Tier 1 genomic alterations were classified as
actionable based on FDA approvals at the time of review, which
was in May 2024.
Across the entire study cohort, 37% of patients had an actionable
alteration on their first instance of plasma genomic profiling.
And in the 427 patients with a liquid biopsy in the treatment-naive
setting, 36% of these patients had an alteration
captured by a liquid biopsy that was associated with an FDA-approved
genotype-matched targeted therapy.
And the breakdown of these alterations is shown in the pie chart here, and you can
see that they most commonly occurred in EGFR and KRAS, which is what we expected.
And ultimately, 22% of these treatment-naive patients initiated a
PCGP-matched targeted therapy within 30 days of the liquid biopsy
results.
We then wanted to understand what was the relationship between ctDNA
detectability and overall survival in the treatment-naive
subset. And as we expected, patients with undetectable
ctDNA had significantly better overall survival than those with one
to two mutations or three or more mutations detected by PCGP.
And importantly, patients who received a genotype-targeted therapy based on an
actionable alteration identified by PCGP had
significantly better overall survival compared to those who did not.
And these findings jointly indicate that alterations captured by liquid biopsy are
clinically informative, even for non-actionable alterations whose
density is still offering valuable insight into patient survival.
And when liquid biopsy is capturing actionable alterations, it's directly
enhancing clinical outcomes for patients with non-small cell lung cancer
by enabling timely matching to highly effective genotype-targeted therapies.
We then wanted to investigate in which clinical scenarios PCGP was
uniquely informing clinical management, in addition to the information that
we're gleaning from tissue next-generation sequencing in these patients.
And so across first, second, and third instance of plasma genotyping,
liquid biopsy was uniquely informative in 84, nine, and three cases
respectively, which totaled 13% of the total study cohort.
And this most commonly occurred when tissue testing was clinically
infeasible. But we also saw liquid biopsy uniquely guiding
patient management by improving on turnaround time compared to tissue
next-generation sequencing by detecting mutations not found in
tissue-matched samples that were matched to FDA-approved targeted therapies,
by indicating the absence of acquired resistance alterations, and also
by detecting mutations not found in tissue-matched samples that met clinical
trial criteria. And so these findings characterize, or underscore
previously characterized advantages of liquid biopsy in a real-world
institutional setting, and also underscore that plasma genomic profiling can
offer unique clinical benefit to patients with non-small cell lung cancer
beyond the information we're getting from tissue genotyping.
Among the 214 patients with EGFR-driven non-small cell lung cancer,
liquid biopsy was especially informative and uniquely guided management in
28% of cases versus 13% of the general
study population. And at the time of progression on EGFR TKI
therapy, 22% of these patients had actionable alterations
captured by plasma genomic profiling, of which 58% of these
patients were matched to a genotype-targeted therapy based on those findings.
And we're showing in the swimmer's plot here 12 representative cases of patients
with EGFR mutant non-small cell lung cancer whose management was guided
by serial PCGP. And you can appreciate the liquid biopsy-informed
therapy switches shown as these black boxes in the swimmer's plot, which were
predominantly driven by acquired EGFR T790M
alterations, EGFR C797S alterations, as
well as MET amplifications and BRAF
alterations.We then wanted to
understand the landscape of on- and off-target putative resistance
mutations by EGFR TKI treatment line for TKIs of
various types, including osimertnib and first and second-generation EGFR
TKIs that were captured by plasma germline profiling in
this EGFR mutant patient subpopulation.
So in the landscape plot here, each patient represents a column, and patients are
clustered according to EGFR TKI line of therapy, starting with
TKI-naive on the left and proceeding to post-third-line EGFR
TKI therapy on the right. And EGFR primary and secondary
alterations are shown on the top, and the remaining alterations are clustered
according to cancer hallmark and pathway.
And so in terms of on-target resistance, as we expected, we saw EGFR
T790M alterations emerging after first and second-generation
TKI therapy versus EGFR C797S and
compound mutations being acquired after first-line
osimertnib. EGFR primary activating mutations
commonly co-occurred with EGFR amplifications in the
treatment-naive setting, but this was significantly less frequent after subsequent
EGFR TKI therapy. In addition, EGFR mutations
commonly co-occurred with cell cycle alterations throughout therapeutic settings.
And in terms of off-target resistance, MET amplifications, which can be
technically challenging to capture by liquid biopsy, were frequently detected
after first-line EGFR TKI therapy, as were alterations in the
PI3K pathway. Oncogenic alterations in the RAS
pathway, including the actionable BRAP V600E alteration,
were captured across lines of therapy.
And this really highlights the value of liquid biopsy for characterizing drivers
of therapy resistance and enabling informed decision-making in the
clinical setting at the time of disease progression.
Similarly, as a proportion of the total number of co-mutations,
PI3K pathway alterations were commonly detected after first and second-line
therapy, whereas RAS pathway alterations also spanned later lines of
therapy. And this finding is highlighting both shared and distinct
activation of signaling pathways and cancer hallmarks in the
development of acquired therapeutic resistance that drive cancer cell fitness
um, and highlight the value of plasma germline profiling for characterizing
what is driving resistance to EGFR TKI therapy over multiple
lines of therapy.
So to conclude, plasma germline profiling identifies actionable alterations and
uniquely informs management of patients with non-small cell lung cancer,
helping match patients to genotype-targeted therapies that confer a clear survival
benefit. PCGP informs serial clinical decisions with
rapid turnaround time and high feasibility while more optimally capturing
tumor heterogeneity and evolution.
PCGP at the time of disease progression identified actionable drivers of
resistance enabling therapeutic intervention, and in patients with
EGFR-driven non-small cell lung cancer, liquid biopsy captured differential
activation of cancer hallmarks and resistance pathways depending on therapeutic
context and line of therapy. And I'm happy to announce that the full
manuscript is being concurrently published with this presentation in "Cancer
Research Communications," and you can access the full manuscript at the embedded QR
code.
I want to end by thanking the Molecular Oncology Lab at Hopkins Thoracic, led
by Dr. Elsa Ignastu, as well as special support from the Dariel
Linehan Fellowship in Thoracic Medical Oncology, the Johns Hopkins University
Undergraduate Research Fellowship Program, obviously the wonderful co-authors of
this study, as well as our patients and their families for enabling this work.
Thank you for your attention, and I look forward to your questions.
We have time for questions.
Great talk. I was just curious, like for MET and some of the other
ones that you could look in the tissue,
how did you guys look at concordance between
at time of resistance between blood and tumor?
Yeah, we did. And so this is a great question because as you mentioned, MET
amplifications can be technically challenging to capture by liquid biopsy.
And so there were about 79 cases of liquid biopsy at the time of
disease progression after TKI therapy, and we did capture in about
10% of those cases MET amplification with liquid biopsy.
And so in some cases with concurrent tissue biopsy and liquid biopsy,
we were not able to capture the MET amplification by PCGP, which is potentially
reflecting technical challenges, particularly in the context of low tumor burden or
intrathoracic disease, for example.
So yes, we were able to capture these structural alterations by liquid biopsy, but
there were some instances of discordance.
Great work.
Thank you.
Another questions. Another question.
Did you examine patients treated with immunotherapy and the rate
of therapy guidance in those patients?
Yeah. So there were a few patients where, for example, they would be given
immunotherapy based on an MSI-high score by liquid biopsy.
But generally speaking, our focus was on oncogene-driven non-small cell lung cancer
for which immunotherapy is thought to have somewhat limited efficacy.
Can I ask you one? So how do you envision this approach
in late versus early disease using this liquid
biopsy?
Yeah. So I think the focus of this study was predominantly on these metastatic
cancers where we're able to, particularly in the context of higher circulating
tumor burden, where it may be easier to capture drivers of therapy resistance.
I will say that we are performing a similar analysis on patients managed from
2022 onward, and where potentially PCGP might be used
more in the early-stage setting, it might be used more serially.
So we could try to capture not only what is happening maybe with these early-stage
patients, but also what we're seeing with, for example, fourth-generation EGFR
TKIs or the MET EGFR bispecifics.
Thank you.
And do you think there's a role beyond targeted panels?
Whole genome methylation. Where do you see that
playing a role in this population?
Yeah, it's a great point, and I think this will be at a future area of analysis.
But I think we were focused really on what is the CLIA-approved assays in the
context of non-small cell lung cancer, and think in particular, when you're able to
capture these particular alterations with high depth, if you
don't fix gene panel sequencing, that can lead to, as we were trying to show,
matching to these highly effective genotype-targeted therapies.
But it definitely would be worth exploring and might be an area of follow-up in our
future work to look at, especially as whole genome assays
or methylation assays become CLIA approved in terms of management of
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer, what that clinical utility looks like.
Fantastic.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you very much.
All right, so
the next talk is going to be...
All right. So the next abstract is going to be presented by Dr. Stabile.
Did I say it correctly? So, and the title of the talk is Feasibility of
Plasma ctDNA for Detecting Brain Metastasis
Specific Alterations in Lung Cancer. Please.
Thank you to the organizers for the opportunity to present our work
today. I'll be discussing the use of plasma
ctDNA to detect brain-specific genomic alterations
with a focus on MET amplifications in lung cancer brain
metastases.
I have no disclosures to report.
Non-small cell lung cancer has the highest frequency of metastasis to the
brain among all solid tumors and is associated with poor
clinical outcomes.
The brain is often the site of disease progression, and after
radiation, there are no effective therapies, and no brain-specific
targeted therapies exist.
Several seminal studies have identified brain metastasis-specific
targetable genomic alterations, highlighting the
need to identify therapeutic targets in brain metastases to improve
outcomes in this challenging patient population.
Our team has had a long-standing interest in the hepatocyte growth factor,
HGF-MET signaling pathway, which is frequently activated in
lung cancer. This can occur through HGF or MET
protein overexpression, MET point mutations,
exon 14 skipping mutations, amplification, and
fusions. All which can increase MET activity.
Importantly, MET alterations are targetable, and we currently have
two FDA-approved MET TKIs, cabmetinib and tepotinib,
with another, selvalinib, on the horizon.
The HGF-MET signaling pathway has also been implicated in brain
metastasis biology. In this regard,
HGF has been shown to be secreted from tumor-associated
astrocytes, and increased phosphorylated MET has been
detected in brain metastases.
In order to further understand the role of MET in lung cancer brain
metastases, we performed MET fluorescence in
situ hybridization in a large cohort of primary
lung adenocarcinomas and brain metastases.
We found that MET amplification, defined by a MET to CEP
ratio greater than two, was significantly
more common in the brain metastases at a rate of
16.4%, compared to only 3.7%
in primary lung tumors.
We also identified a significant enrichment of MET mutations in
the brain metastases.
These MET-amplified
brain tumors are a distinct biological subtype with
unique genomic features, an altered tumor immune
microenvironment, metabolic reprogramming with a reliance on
glycolysis,
and increased EMT signaling.
Although these are associated with poor patient survival, as shown by the
red
line and the survival curve, MET-amplified brain
metastases do respond to MET TKIs in preclinical
models, and clinical activity has been
reported in several patient case
reports.
MET amplification is therefore a clinically meaningful example
of the molecular divergence between primary lung tumors and brain
metastases, and this divergence highlights the need
for non-invasive approaches to detect this brain-specific MET
amplification to identify patients who may benefit from
MET-targeted therapies.
Even though while blood-based ctDNA
sensitivity for brain metastases is known to be limited,
we hypothesized that MET alterations detected in ctDNA
would be found more often in patients with brain
metastases. Using a retrospective cohort of
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer patients that underwent standard of care
ctDNA testing with the Guardant 360 platform at our
institution, we evaluated the presence of brain metastases
on MRI scans.
We found that MET alterations detected by
ctDNA were significantly more common in patients
with brain metastases than those without, and this was driven
by MET amplification, not MET
mutations.This supports the potential of
ctDNA as a non-invasive method for detecting brain
metastasis-specific MET amplification.
To prospectively test this, we analyzed pre
and post-craniotomy plasma samples, along with matched brain
metastasis tissue from patients with metastatic non-small cell
lung cancer undergoing surgery for symptomatic brain
lesions. Twenty-eight patients were included in this
study. Peripheral blood was
collected pre-surgery at day zero, referred to as P1
plasma, and post-surgery prior to systemic therapy
initiation, referred to as P2 plasma.
Brain metastasis tissue was collected at the time of surgery and prepared as
FFPE blocks.
Samples were sequenced using the Predicinn CARE 200 gene
NGS assay and analyzed using Predicinn's DeepSeek
bioinformatics pipeline.
After excluding cases for insufficient viable tumor, low
tumor fraction, or failed QC, we
analyzed 13 complete sets, three partial
sets of tissue in P1 plasma only, and seven
tissue-only samples, for a total of 23 brain metastasis
samples.
We asked if alterations detected in ctDNA at baseline were
absent or reduced in post-craniotomy ctDNA,
and if brain met specific alterations found in the tumor tissue could also
be detected in ctDNA.
This slide depicts the molecular landscape of lung cancer brain
metastases in our cohort. The most common alterations
were TP53, RB1,
CDK2A and 2B, and PIK3CA,
each present in more than half of the samples.
Additionally, clinically actionable alterations including the
classical EGFR TKI sensitizing mutations,
as well as the targetable KRAS G12C mutation, were
each detected in three patients.
And relevant to our research interests, MET amplification was
detected in six out of 23 patients, or
26%, consistent with the findings
that I reported in our earlier cohort of close to 200
cases.
While many alterations were shared between the brain
metastasis tissue and the two plasma samples, complete
loss of an alteration in the P2 plasma that was
detected in both the P1 plasma and the brain tissue
was rare, occurring in only one of 13 patients,
and this was the loss of an EGFR amplification.
However, a decrease of more than 50% variant allele
frequency was seen for multiple variants in an additional 12 of
13 patients, despite similar percent tumor
fractions, suggesting that ctDNA shed from brain metastases
is possible.
Notably, amplifications or deletions in
CDK2A or B, KEAP1, and
NF1 were only detected in the brain tissue, and
only one of two MET amplifications were
detected in the plasma in the complete sets, and one of
six when we included all patients.
One particularly interesting case involved a patient who
received five fractions of postoperative brain
radiation therapy to the tumor bed, ending just one day
before the P2 sample collection.
In the P2 plasma,
we identified MET and MYC
amplifications and a TP53 deletion.
These were present in the brain metastasis tissue, but were
absent in the P1 ctDNA
sample. We also compared the variant allele
frequencies and CNVs between P1 and P2 in
this patient.
Across the board, as you can see in this heat map, VAFs and
CNVs were increased in the P2
plasma collection.
And the majority of the alterations highlighted here in
red were increased more than we would have expected based on the tumor
fraction.
This suggests that radiation therapy may enhance tumor DNA
shedding, potentially improving ctDNA detection of
brain-specific alterations.
To summarize, molecular divergence between primary lung
tumors and brain metastases highlights the need for
non-invasive detection of brain metastasis-specific
genomic alterations, and MET amplification
is a good example of this. Brain met specific
alterations can be detected in plasma ctDNA, but
sensitivity still remains a major limitation.
Improved detection will require assays with greater sensitivity
and optimized collection timing, such as the example that I showed
with post-radiation therapy, and this will be essential to
improve yield and clinical utility.
To our knowledge, this is the only study to date that uses matched
pre and post-craniotomy plasma and paired brain MET tissue,
allowing us to directly evaluate ctDNA detection of
brain-specific alterations.
Our ongoing studies include optimizing sampling windows and
assay sensitivity in both plasma and CSF,
and integrating this with radiogenomic modeling.
Finally, I would like to acknowledge our team and collaborators that contributed to
this work at the University of Pittsburgh Hillman Cancer Center,
The James at The Ohio State University, and our industry
partners at Predicinn.As well as our funding sources
and most importantly, the patients and families who made this study possible.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. So we have time for some questions.
Is this on? Yeah.
Very nice talk. Thank you. Barbara Zientek of FireBio. I have a quick question.
Do you think that that post-radiotherapy signal could be
contributed if something changes with the blood-brain barrier?
That's our hypothesis, yes.
Okay.
Yes.
Well, I always thought that DNA, RNA, protein doesn't pass, right?
That's why the EV, extracellular vesicles, are so interesting for
these brain mets. But if you see a signal with regular ctDNA, it could
be because something changes to the barrier.
Yes. And we're very interested in looking at this
before and after FRS as well. So that's sort of
our next step.
Yeah.
Very cool. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Just to that point,
what do you think the optimal timing will be?
Because I noticed in that case, very interesting case, it
was, I think, one day after completion of the five gray-
Right
... times five regimen, and it was the operative bed.
Is that right?
It was to the tumor bed, correct.
So it wasn't an intact metastasis.
Correct.
So what do you think? How might this vary based
on intact metastases being treated and timing
of collection?
So that's exactly what we're trying to work on now is to optimize the
sampling timing. So we will try
multiple time points to try to figure out the
optimum time period.
So we did have some other cases that also had radiation therapy, but
the timing was either
before the collection or after the collection.
So we weren't able to look at that in our small cohort, unfortunately.
But I think that's the question that we're interested in-
Yeah
... answering, is what is the timing that's going to be needed
for this?
Yeah. That'll be interesting.
Even with that cohort that you have, if you have
cases that are further removed, that would be
interesting.
What sensitivity do you think you need?
So I do think that
this is one of the most sensitive assays out there,
especially for copy number. That's why we chose to work with PrediSyn
for this. But I still think that even if you have a very
sensitive assay, we're still going to have to do something to
permeabilize the blood-brain barrier to detect this.
So maybe some of the more sensitive MRD assays,
like the ultrasensitive assays, might be useful for this as well.
Okay.
Thank you so much. Thank you for that.
Thank you.
Great talk.
All right. Our third speaker is Evi
Leonido from University of Athens.
"AXL mRNA Overexpression in CTCs as a New Potential
Liquid Biopsy Biomarker in Non-Small Cell Lung Cancer."
Thank you. First of all, thank you very much for giving us the opportunity to
present our work at the AACR.
And
here are my disclosures.
as you all know, liquid biopsy has a lot of components to
be analyzed beyond cell-free DNA, like
CTCs, like epigenetic alterations, like
circulating microRNAs, and EVs as well.
And through the years, a lot of technologies have been developed for
liquid biopsy, and
all this is very challenging,
and it has a lot of applications in clinical practice.
We hear a lot on MRD, risk of relapse,
prognostic, treatment selection, early detection of resistance,
and tumor heterogeneity.
CTC analysis is very important for all these steps.
There are a lot of studies through the years that show clearly
that through the analysis of CTCs, we can get a lot of
information for all these steps that were mentioned for liquid biopsy
analysis.
What is important in CTC analysis is
that beyond DNA analysis that we can do, of
course, in CTCs at the mutation level and
rearrangements,
and epigenetics as well, this can be done in ctDNA.
But beyond this, in CTC, we have
more information. First of all, we can do protein analysis
on CTC.
We can check for the expression of informative antigen like
HER2/Trop2. We can do CTC numeration that
I have to say that almost 20 years earlier has
gained FDA clearance for prostate, breast, and
colorectal cancer. We can do RNA analysis, and
we can check for gene expression for important markers like
PD-L1, ARV7, AXL, that I'm going to present now.
And moreover, we can do live cell analysis, and we can have
CTC-derived cell lines.
Moreover, we can check tumor heterogeneity at the single-cell
levels. We now have the technologies to do that, and
we can also check the molecular
characteristics of CTC clusters that are important for
metastasis.
And here in this figure, you can see what
important markers we can see in CTCs, in breast cancer,
in prostate cancer, and in non-small cell lung
cancer.I will focus
on AXL.
In our university,
we have a lab that is, let's say, based on the US
standards, CLIA lab.
In Europe, we say ISO 15189 for
liquid biopsy analysis, for gene expression in CTCs,
and for droplet digital PCR as well for ESR1
mutations.
I will focus on non-small cell lung cancer, and relative to what
I'm going to present,
are these publications where we checked for gene expression in
CTC,
where we
have seen a dynamic role of EMT and PD-L1 during osimertinib
treatment. We have checked in the same samples,
in CTC and paired samples on cell-free DNA,
EGFR mutations, and we have also checked for
epigenetic markers, especially DNA methylation
analysis. I'm not going to go through this
in detail, but in most cases we have different time
points in osimertinib-treated patients, and
CTC were reached for
downstream molecular analysis using the size-based
Parsortix system. And here is a heat
map of gene expression analysis in CTC during these three time points.
Direct comparison of EGFR mutations in
primary tumor in CTCs and cell-free DNA,
and using crystal digital PCR,
and also epigenetic alterations.
All this is showing that CTC are giving complementary
information to ctDNA analysis.
Now, I will go to AXL. AXL is a
tyrosine kinase receptor and is involved in EMT.
And is involved in cell survival, invasion, metastasis,
and resistance to EGFR, TKIs, and immune
checkpoint inhibitors.
AXL overexpression play a key role in the
modulation of immunosuppressive microenvironment, and
lately there are a lot of new drugs that have
cleared by the FDA to target AXL positive tumors.
And as you can see here, among the resistant mechanism
to osimertinib in EGFR mutated non-small cell lung
cancer, AXL signal pathway is one that
is very important since through
EMT can turn
this type of cancer to small cell
lung cancer.
Based on all this, there are now drugs
that are TKI based.
They're based on monoclonal antibodies,
as well as based on ADCs. And
these types of drugs are all designed based on this
AXL signal pathway. And there are a number of
clinical trials that are ongoing at the moment,
and they include AXL
targeting,
together
with well-defined and well-applied
therapies for non-small cell lung cancer.
So in the present study, we evaluated for
the first time AXL mRNA overexpression in
size-based enriched CTCs using the Parsortix device
in longitudinal liquid biopsy sample from two independent groups
of non-small cell lung cancer patients.
We have group one, that are patients under osimertinib
treatment at four time,
before treatment, after first cycle of
therapy, every three months at a disease progression.
And group B, where it's an independent group of patients
before and during immunotherapy.
This is experimental flowchart of the study.
This is the number of patients, the different time points.
This is group A, group B, and of course, we have a
number of healthy controls that we used.
As you will see, it's very important to define the cutoff for this
overexpression of AXL. In all these cases, we
used a size-based CTC
enrichment. It's not isolation, it's enrichment,
as most
assays are doing, except single cell isolation of
CTCs. And then following that, we do total
RNA after enrichment through the Parsortix system.
We do total RNA isolation, cDNA,
we check quality control. We have developed
RTqPCR assays that are fully analytical validated in terms of
analytical sensitivity, specificity, spiked samples in
terms of known number of cells analyzed.
And we use the relative quantification approach.
I'm not going to go in details in the methodology, but
this is thoroughly analytical validated.
So
in this
figure, you can see in group A, at different time
points, each dot represents one time point that these
different patients have been checked, and the red dots
indicate the cases where AXL was
overexpressed in circulating tumor cells.
So overexpression was detected in almost 13% of patients at
baseline before treatment, at 16% of patients
after the first cycle of therapy, in 9% during
treatment, and in 12% at progression of disease.
In group BIn most cases, we have
no AXL overexpression before
immunotherapy, but
after immunotherapy, we have a few patients like this one
and these patients
where AXL was overexpressed after their immunotherapy.
It was only in three patients, these three patients, that AXL
overexpression was detected before, but not during after therapy.
And here are the expression levels based on the cutoff
value before and after for 71 pairs.
So, as a conclusion, I have to say that in the whole
cohort of patients with non-small cell lung cancer, we detected an
increased number of patients with AXL positive enriched CTC
after first cycle of treatment. And following the non-small cell lung
cancer patients with AXL positive CTCs to disease
progression, we have a heterogeneous pattern of gene
expression among them.
And this is highlighting to us the significance of personalized treatment.
And our results indicate that longitudinal monitoring in non-small cell lung
cancer patients based on the molecular characterization
of CTCs and AXL overexpression could be a precious
tool for the assessment of osimertinib efficacy and
early therapeutic intervention with AXL inhibitors.
Concerning immunotherapy, we have also seen that AXL is
overexpressed in enriched CTCs in an increased number of
patients after three or four cycles of anti-PD-1
therapy compared to baseline.
And
as a conclusion, I have to say that our results indicated
that this monitoring of AXL overexpression in CTC
deserves to be further evaluated through larger clinical
studies as a potential biomarker for anti-AXL targeted
therapies in non-small cell lung cancer.
I have to show that ctDNA is a very precious tool.
We
listen to so many talks, but we can see ctDNA as a
smoothie, while we can see CTC analysis, and especially
single-cell analysis, as highly precious because it gives us a
lot of information additional to ctDNA,
even if it's much more difficult and complicated.
I would like to thank all our collaborators in
Greece and abroad, our funding
agencies. I would like
to thank my group, and especially Aliki, which is a
postdoc in my lab, and she did all the work.
Unfortunately, she could not come here to give this presentation.
And finally, I'd like to invite you all to the eighth meeting that we're
organizing on advances in CTC, that will be
in Mykonos, well-known island to all of you, next
October 2027. Thank you.
This abstract is open for questions.
Maybe I can start.
Very provocative at the end there,
showing the power of individual cells.
Do you think we can get to a point where either the
transcripts or even AXL protein
expression could be interrogated on individual circulating tumor
cells as opposed to the bulk approach that you've used?
Yes.
Because all these cells that we have isolated and we have done the molecular
analysis, which is high throughput with size-based enrichment,
this size-based enrichment allow us to
check on the microfluidics chip
directly with immunofluorescence markers.
Using this technology, I didn't have the time to mention, we have done
CMAT amplification, all the markers in osimertinib treated
patients.
We have done FISH analysis, so we can do
imaging on CTCs as well.
And
based on the
value of these results, I think it can be
used downstream, yes. The only problem is with CTC
is that you don't have
the luxury to analyze a sample whenever you want.
In CTC, you have to analyze the sample quite quickly.
And based on this, the technology that we use for size-based enrichment,
which is not affected by EpCAM positivity,
and also detects
EMT cells that are in transition, is very
important, and it's almost automated.
So this
helped us a lot to analyze these more than
300 samples.
Yeah.
Can I ask you something? So did you look into the concordance between
CTC derived AXL versus tissue
expression
or-
Unfortunately, we didn't have
the primary tissues for immunotherapy
patients.
In osimertinib patients, we do have the
primary tumors, but we didn't check AXL
expression.
That might be helpful to see that-
It's very nice. Thank you
... these are the best one.
Thank you. Yes. We can do it, yeah.
And do you know what the therapeutic relevant
expression level would be for the different
drugs?
Within individuals.
Based on other studies, you mean how many CTCs
should be?
No, I mean, the levels of RNA expression that
you're seeing, and can you infer that they are
therapeutically important based on treatment with different AXL
inhibitors?
If we have in mind that these are patients that have been over-treated
with anything,
and the AXL is a marker that is overexpressed
in CTCs, I'm not an oncologist,
but I think that it will be interesting to check further with clinical studies
and see whether this overexpression
can be targeted in an efficient way and help patients for
overall survival.
Yeah.
And
based on PD-L1 expression in CTCs, this has been shown in a
completely different marker, but the same concept.
All right. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right. So the next abstract is going to be presented by Dr. Zhu.
The title of the abstract is "Circulating Tumor
Cell-Informed Pipeline for
Rapid Personalization of Synergistic Cytokine-Armed
CAR-NK Cell Therapy in Pancreatic Ductal
Adenocarcinoma." Dr. Zhu, please.
All right.
Good afternoon. My name is Yin Zhu.
I'm a fourth-year PhD student from the University of Michigan, and it's my
pleasure today, and thank you for the chairs to have me for this
session to present my PhD work. So here's my disclosure
and my PI's disclosure.
So I'd like to open first by talking about PDAC.
PDAC is a very lethal disease as we know it, and the main reason
why this disease is such a lethal disease is because when we
diagnose these patients, they are usually at a metastatic stage, meaning that
when we have advanced patients, their tumors are usually unresectable,
and chemotherapy becomes their only standard treatment option, which only
have a very limited life expectancy for these patients.
As I show by the bar plot over here, that the metastatic disease patients usually
have a very, very low five-year survival rate for these tumors.
So this really calls out for exploring alternative therapeutic
options to treat these patients more effectively.
Among many other strategies people have come up with, immunotherapy has been
showing a lot of promises, especially NK-cell-based
immunotherapies. So NK cells is this innate immunity that we
have in our body that recognizes malignant signals as NK activation
signals to initiate tumor-killing activities.
The advantage of NK-based therapy is that they do not really require antigen
recognition or antigen presentation by these tumor cells so that the
NK cells can rapidly kill the targeted tumors.
And also, NK cells can be allogenically transferred, so meaning that NK cells from
a healthy donor can be given directly to a patient, making this
therapy very, very flexible.
And lastly, the NK cells have a very high safety profile as compared to its
counterpart T cells, as been shown by the mounting evidence in the clinical trial
and the preclinical trials. We can further augment the
NK cell activity against tumors by adding a chimeric antigen
receptor construct onto these cells by making them into a CAR-NK cells.
So this CAR construct will then recognize specific tumor antigens and
exert killing activities against the tumor cells that's expressing these
antigens.
However, even with all these progresses, we have seen a very limited efficacies
for immunotherapy against PDAC, and this is really largely due to that the PDAC
have a very immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment and also the
PDAC is notoriously known as a highly inter-patient and intra-tumor
heterogeneous tumor, so that the resistant subtype or resistant phenotype of
the tumor can rapidly develop by essentially
losing the NK cell activation domains and also the CAR-NK
targets as we treat these tumors.
So ultimately, to have an effective immunotherapy to treat PDAC,
we really need to think of strategies to maintain these NK cells or these
immune cells' anti-tumor efficacy within the tumor, and also
have a strategy to enhance target recognition and
identification, so we can fine-tune our therapy as we treat these patients.
So we have come up with engineering strategies to overcome both of these
issues, and I would like to talk first about the liquid biopsy approach we
used to identify our targets.
So as the previous speakers has mentioned, the circulating tumor cells
are these very important subtypes in our liquid biopsy approach that are
descendant cells from the primary tumors, and they carry important
information of the solid tumor and also contributes to
metastasis. And due to these important features of circulating tumor cells,
we hypothesized that the CTCs can be used as a surrogate
to show the expression of CAR-NK targets expressed in the primary
tumor, meaning that the CTC phenotypes we screened would
very likely to reflect on what is happening within the primary tumor and can
administer appropriate therapy to these patients.
So here's our workflow. Essentially, we would just be needing a tube of blood from
the patients, and we would enrich the CTCs with our
in-house designed and manufactured microfluidic device called Labyrinth.
So this Labyrinth really utilize the feature that
the CTCs are slightly larger than all the other blood cells in our bloodstream,
and by manipulating the microfluidic forces within
the device, we can actually achieve a sorting of
these CTCs into different fluidic lanes, eventually resulting in a highly
enriched CTC population out of our microfluidic device.
So once we have enriched our CTCs, we can use them to identify
our CAR-NK targets via proteomic analysis.
We will further then verify this CAR-NK target
selection via a tumor biopsy sample to just make sure we have the
right targets.As a preliminary screening, we have picked
mesothelin and the MUC4 as our two very potent CAR-NK
targets. Now, both of these proteins are minimally expressed in the healthy
organs and are significantly upregulated in the pancreatic cancer, as you can
see on this volcano plot over here.
So here's our immunofluorescence staining panels that we have used to identify
CTCs. We use CD45 to distinguish white blood cells,
which we'll exclude from our analysis, and cytokeratin to
identify our CTCs. Then we further use
these antibodies to stain for mesothelin or MUC4 expression to further subtype our
CTC populations.
So out of the 33 patients we have collected so far, these patients all
have various cancer stages, which is very important because we can
administer-- which just means we can administer CAR-NK cell therapies to
patients in different cancer stages, too.
And to sum up, so we have observed a very homogeneous
CTC enumeration numbers across these cancer stages,
and so is the mesothelin-positive CTC populations.
But very interestingly, we have observed that the MUC4-positive
CTCs are somewhat enriched in these metastatic patients, which
actually aligns very well with prior literature findings.
And if we look at everything in a more holistic fashion, we have observed that
there is 87% of patients carry CTCs with at least one
of our CAR-NK cell targets. And more interestingly, if we look
at these patient distributions, we see that there are patients with
exclusive MUC4 expression CTCs or exclusive mesothelin expression
CTCs, meaning that it's very likely that if we gave these patients
appropriate CAR treatment, it will exert a better
tumor-killing efficacy.
But does this really match with the primary tumor?
So to answer this, we have collected some tumor biopsy samples, and we did
the similar immunofluorescence stainings. Here, cytokeratin is stained green.
So out of the eight patients that we have collected matched CTC and primary
tumors thus far,
we have seen that seven out of the eight patients matches with at least one target,
meaning that their mesothelin or MUC4 phenotype
matches between CTC and the primary tumors.
And two out of the eight patients have a match with both targets, meaning that both
MUC4 and mesothelin phenotype are matched.
If we look at this more directly in the scatter plot, we have seen that
this CTC and tumor tissue expression level
is highly correlative, meaning that if we
detect a highly mesothelin-positive CTC, it's very
likely that these tumor tissues will also have a high level of
MUC4 expression.
So this really tells us that CTC could really carry the phenotype of the primary
tumor to aid our CAR-NK cell target selections, really
informs our therapy to be more precise.
But when we administer this therapy to the patient, when it
goes into tumor, would it actually exert a very high
efficacy to kill these tumors? If not, we might need to do
something else to these CAR-NK cells.
So here in this cartoon is a very conventional CAR-NK cell design that we
can put into our NK cells. To further augment the functionality
of these NK cells, we can actually add another domain to let it
secrete their own cytokine to support their own activities.
This is called the cytokine-armed CAR-NK cells.
So these CAR-NK cells, as they are proliferating or as they are culturing in
vivo, ex vivo, they can produce their own cytokine to support
their own
functions. So in our model, we have picked
IL-12 as an NK activation cytokine and IL-15 as
an NK proliferative cytokine. And due to just the really complementary
role of 12 and 15, we further hypothesized that what if we
co-culture both IL-12 and IL-15 producing CARs,
would this create a synergistic effect which would further boost the
anti-tumor efficacies?
So in this killing assay we have conducted, we have seen very clearly that
when we treat BxPC3, a MUC4-positive pancreatic cancer cell
line,
we see that when we treat them with anti-MUC4 CAR-NK cells,
the killing efficiency is significantly boosted compared to a
non-modified conventional C NK cells.
And we have also seen that with the cytokine-armed strategy,
these NK cells have almost completely eliminated this
tumor within this 2D killing culture.
A similar story can be seen in another cell line, AsPC1, which is a
mesothelin expression cell line, and we treat them with anti-mesothelin CARs.
We further probed the activation phenotypes of these NK cells,
and as we can see from here that these NK cells, when they have cytokine arms, they
have a very high level of granzyme B production, which is an NK cell killing
molecule. And what's more pleasing for us to see is that the
interferon gamma, which is an NK cell activation marker, was highly
expressed in the IL-12 or IL-12 and 15 syngeneous
cultures. And what's more interesting is that this
activation of NK cells only happens when they are exposed to tumor
cells, showing that there is a very high specificity of this
model. So with all these activation phenotypes, we want to see
if our NK cells can kill the tumors in a long-term killing assay.
So here we have designed an assay that we're basically re-exposing the
NK cells with fresh batches of tumor cells.
And here's the result. So we have observed that IL-15 and
12 armed CAR-NK cells can actually exert a very
long-term killing efficiencies.
And when we further analyze these cells at their endpoints of day 16,
we have seen that both the IL-12 and 15 armed CARs have
retained a very high activation profile.
When we further challenged our model with a spheroid
assay, we have seen that the IL-12 and 15 CAR again completely
eradicated the spheroid on day 12, which is very
promising.So we further tested in the preliminary
animal study that when we inject these single dose of CAR NK cells
into each mice, we have seen a very tremendous tumor suppressions
with the cell-armed NK cells. And what's more pleasing for us
to see is that when we have our 12 and 15 synergistic armed
CARs, the survival benefits to these tumor-bearing mice is tremendously
higher.
So to conclude, we have seen that our 12 and 15 creates a
synergistic effect to initiate tumor-killing efficiencies.
And we further propose that in the future, immunotherapies might go really
hand-in-hand with a liquid biopsy approach to further guide the therapeutic
accuracy. Essentially, we can really sample our tumor samples
or with our liquid biopsies to inform what targets we should
go after with our immunotherapies.
And then we treat these patients with a follow-up sample later on after the
treatment, so we can further see if there's any changes within the
tumor molecular landscape, and then readjust therapy in real time,
providing a very flexible therapeutics, achieving a treatment
that could co-involves with the tumor.
With that, I would like to thank my lab at Michigan and also
our collaborators at the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. This abstract is open for discussion.
Any comments, questions?
Maybe I can start with... So you mentioned
the CAR NK expression-
Yeah
... target expression changes over time and also in different CTC
populations. So how do you envision using this if
patients undergo treatment and the CTC, the target expression changes?
Right. I think target expression change could really be due to
the actual changes in the tumor landscape.
So it could be
reflective of what's happening in the tumor.
So I think we would envision that when we first
sample the tumor. So when most of the PDAC patients come into clinic,
they will sample the tumor biopsy first.
So we have a baseline knowledge of what is expressed in this tumor
microenvironment. And then after that, whatever's happening at the CTCs
will be reflective of whatever's changed within the tumor.
Along the same lines, you compared with primary
tumor expression.
Yes.
Did you have any access to metastases?
So for this patient, no. Unfortunately, we do not have metastases.
And a lot of these patients, the samples were taken before they
start treatment, so we do not have the follow-up biopsy for the
metastatic sites-
Mm
... or after the treatments.
That would be really interesting to see.
And did you
look at specificity for those markers in
non-cancer-bearing
subjects?
Unfortunately, not yet, but I think it would be very interesting to look at it.
And I think it will be quite
minimally expressed, especially none of these targets were expressing
in most of our healthy normal organs.
So this will be pretty rare to detect, I believe.
All right.
Thank you so much.
Thank you very much.
All right. So next we'll welcome up Hannah Robinson
from University of Colorado, who will speak on ctDNA
clearance dynamics in MSI-high colorectal cancer
treated with immune checkpoint inhibitors.
So I'd like to thank the organizers for the opportunity to present this
work on behalf of my co-authors. So we'll be shifting a little bit
further towards the clinic for this talk to look at ctDNA and
MSI high metastatic colorectal cancer.
I have no disclosures relevant to disclose.
So we have among the most robust data for ctDNA in
colon cancer, where we know that ctDNA clearance in
patients with locally advanced disease following curative intent
resection is highly prognostic, and we await further
data to clarify its role as a predictive biomarker.
We have less robust data that's specific to patients with a
subset of MSI high disease. The data that we
do have for MSI high colorectal cancer is largely
derived from the perioperative setting, where we also have
seen that ctDNA clearance is
prognostic.
We have very limited data for ctDNA dynamics for patients
with metastatic MSI high colorectal cancer who are
undergoing treatment with ICI therapy.
So why do we need better monitoring tools for patients with
MSI high metastatic disease? Well, we know that ICI
therapy has really transformed treatment for these patients, and we
can see durable responses for a large portion of these
patients. Despite this, we still have a number of clinical
questions and problems.
First, treatment resistance remains a concern.
So we know that a subset of patients do go on to
develop resistance, and up to 15 to 20% of patients may
develop early or primary resistance to ICI
therapy.
Second, the role of resection for oligo-metastatic
disease in patients who respond well to ICI therapy
remains controversial, and we worry that we may be taking patients to surgery
where it's not needed, where we resect
post-treatment scar without viable tumor.Third,
the optimal duration of ICI therapy remains unclear.
And so we don't yet understand how best to optimize the
risks of toxicity with prolonged treatment with the potential
benefits to efficacy.
Imaging that we use to try to address these questions can be misleading.
So we know we can see pseudoprogression or apparent growth of
tumors due to immune cell infiltration,
rather than true disease progression.
And we are also left with residual masses after response to
ICI therapy that are difficult to differentiate between true
residual disease versus non-viable post-treatment scar
tissue.
ctDNA can reflect tumor burden in real time,
and this therefore has the potential to answer some of these ongoing
questions.
The objective of our study was to describe ctDNA clearance
patterns in correlation with survival in patients with
MSI-high metastatic colorectal cancer undergoing initial
therapy with ICI.
So to answer this, we utilized Natera's real-world database.
We identified patients with MSI-high metastatic
colorectal cancer who were undergoing monitoring with Signatera
ctDNA testing.
We selected patients who were receiving their initial treatment with ICI
therapies. Patients were permitted to have received prior
chemotherapy. We also selected patients who had, at
minimum, a ctDNA sample within 12 weeks prior
to ICI therapy start and/or a post-ICI treatment
ctDNA sample.
We obtained data from Signatera ctDNA results as well as
from the Kronos insurance claims database and mortality data
from Veritas, and we used this to look at ctDNA
clearance rates, timing, and correlation with overall survival.
Many of you are familiar with the Signatera ctDNA testing platform,
but this is a tumor-informed platform that uses a single
tissue sample to perform whole-exome sequencing and
identify a unique set of tumor variants.
From this, there's a custom design of a
multiplex PCR NGS assay
that's designed for each patient and targets up to 16
high-ranked tumor variants. This customized assay can then be
used to test for ctDNA concentration in blood samples
from patients over time to obtain longitudinal
data about disease burden.
So we identified a total of 465 patients in our
database with over 4,000 unique ctDNA time
points and a median of seven ctDNA time points per
patient.
Most patients
had primary colon disease as opposed to primary rectal
disease. Eighty percent were of European descent per
whole-exome sequencing ancestry analysis, and
slightly more than half of patients were female.
In terms of ICI therapy, 71% received
pembrolizumab,
14% received dual therapy with ipilimumab and
nivolumab, 12% received nivolumab, and the remaining
2.6% received another PD-1/PD-L1
monotherapy.
About a third of patients in our cohort did have pre-treatment
ctDNA testing available. That was defined as testing
performed within 12 weeks prior to ICI therapy
initiation. Most of these patients, so 73%,
were ctDNA positive at this time point.
A substantial portion of these patients had received prior chemotherapy at
44%.
So this slide shows ctDNA dynamics among the
patients who had confirmed ctDNA positivity prior to
ICI treatment initiation.
So 23% failed to clear ctDNA,
while the majority of patients, or 77%,
achieved ctDNA clearance at at least one time point after treatment
initiation with a median time to clearance of 96 days.
Forty-four percent had early clearance or clearance within
four months of ICI treatment start, and 63%
achieved sustained clearance, or clearance lasting at least
six months, with a median duration of clearance of 526
days.
We next looked at the impact of the first
post-treatment ICI time point among our entire patient
cohort. Here we saw that patients who had a negative
ctDNA result at this time point had significantly
superior overall survival compared to patients who had positive
ctDNA testing, with a hazard ratio of 4.7
and a four-year overall survival of 95% versus
81%, suggesting that ctDNA at this
time point can be or appears to be a valuable
early prognostic marker.
Next, we looked at the impact of ctDNA clearance at any
time after ICI treatment initiation, and we saw that
patients who cleared their ctDNA at any time
had significantly superior overall survival compared to patients who remained
persistently ctDNA positive, with a hazard ratio of
10 and a four-year overall survival of
95.5% versus 66.1%.
So in conclusion, these findings suggest that ctDNA
dynamics are a valuable tool for assessing benefit from ICI
therapy in patients with metastatic MSI-high colorectal
cancerAnd monitoring in our cohort tracked distinct
ctDNA clearance patterns. So consistent with what we know about
ICI efficacy, most patients did achieve ctDNA clearance
at 77% in our cohorts. And importantly,
we did see that early ctDNA negativity was strongly
prognostic for improved overall survival.
So again, appears to be a good early prognostic marker for
these patients. While persistent ctDNA positivity was
associated with markedly inferior overall survival with a hazard
ratio of 10.
This supports further evaluation of ctDNA to guide
ICI use in MSI-high colorectal cancer,
including prospective studies.
And with that, I would like to thank the patients who contributed to this
research. I'd also like to acknowledge my co-authors, so my
fantastic mentor, Christopher Lu,
as well as our wonderful collaborators at Natera.
And then with that, I'd like to open the floor to questions.
Great talk. I know it's small numbers, but any difference between,
say, ipi/nivo versus-
Mm-hmm.
single monotherapy checkpoint inhibitor?
Yeah, no, great question, and I think especially relevant
with treatment decisions that we're making.
We are working on analyzing this data set further,
and we're hoping to present some of that data at ASCO.
Great.
But as of now, not sure.
Okay.
Curious if you have any plans to look at the
dynamics under other modalities other than
ICIs. Have you done that, or are you planning to?
So with this treatment cohort, we focused
on patients receiving specifically
immunotherapy. And so are you asking specifically
for MSI-H
disease or?
Yeah. Or in general.
Yeah. I think there have been other studies looking at other disease
areas. For this study, we really wanted to focus on the MSI-high
patients receiving immunotherapy because I think there are
some really pertinent questions and really a dearth of data.
Thank you.
Martin Cohen with BioCardis and UCSF.
We know from the 8HW study that when
patients are treated
with dual immunotherapy just based on local
MSI or MMR testing,
that there are almost 20% who are actually misclassified.
And so the recommendation is to do
IHC plus PCR-based MSI
determination.
How sure are you that in your study, all these patients that you looked at were
actually MSI high?
So the MSI high determination for this study
was based off of the Signatera testing,
and specifically looking at whole exome sequencing.
So MSI-high
results based off of whole exome sequencing
without IHC paired samples.
Hi, very nice and interesting talk. Thank you so much.
I'm also wondering that whether you guys have looked at any TCR dynamics
associated with this ctDNA dynamics as well in the
same blood samples you guys profile, because this is
longitudinal data. And do you see any pre-existing or any
normal T-cells goes up with, and that's
negatively associated with the ctDNA?
Yeah, so very interesting question.
So with this data set, we're limited to
Signatera ctDNA testing results.
So that's what we have, and then the associated clinical databases.
But very interesting question.
Hello. Hi, I'm here.
You mean like 44% of patients achieved earlier clearance.
Can you be more specific about earlier?
Like how early it is, like 12 days, 24 days?
Mm-hmm.
Like that. ctDNA, can you be more-
Yeah, absolutely. So we define early clearance as clearance within four
months of ICI treatment start. I will say just part of the
limitations of this study being a retrospective study is that we did not have
uniform time points for ctDNA testing in patients.
So some patients just didn't have time points,
and I'd say probably very few, if any, patients had time points
that early. I think you mentioned within a couple weeks of treatment start.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah. Hi, my name is Alan Pathak. I have a question about
sustained ctDNA negativity. I know you talked about
positivity, but do you have any
information about that?
So
specifically in terms of--
So you're asking about patients-
Outcomes.
So
you're asking about outcomes in patients who had sustained...
No, the question really is-
Okay.
... is sustained ctDNA negativity-
Got it
... more correlated with outcomes than just at one time point?
Yeah. So we
have looked at data
in that way, looking at sustained DNA
negativity versus any positivity, and we've also seen
a significant association with improved overall survival.
Is it more significant in terms of magnitude than just one
time point?
To be honest, I'm not sure. So
I'm not sure that we've looked at those two
dynamics head-to-head.
Okay, thank you so much.
Thank you.
I agree. That would be interesting to see if multiple negative time
points, because you showed any single negative time
point.
Mm-hmm.
I had a question just about the data quality and how you can QC
that from the different sources. Is there any way, or you
just have to take it at face value from the insurance database and?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah. So,
I think it depends, I guess, on what specific parts of the data.
So some pieces of the data, we could get information as
well from the signator ctDNA requisition forms, but a lot
of it were limited.
Great. Thank you very much.
Thank you.
All right. We're going to switch gears now.
So the last two talks are going to be about early detection.
So the first talk is going to be by Dr. Yao.
She's going to talk about genomic signatures in red blood cell
DNA-enabled early non-invasive detection of
colorectal neoplasia in multi-center clinical study.
Dr.
Yao.
Okay.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, fine.
Yeah,
just join it.
Okay.
Thanks for the introduction. And, my name is Xinyu Yao, and
I'm from West Lake University in China,
and today I will show our work on tumor-associated red blood
cell DNA and
its potential for early cancer detection.
Mm. I have no relevant disclosures.
Colorectal cancer remains a leading cause of cancer mortality,
and screening is critical, but
the current non-invasive test has limited sensitivity
in low-burden disease. So on the right is a
FDA-approved stool-based and blood-based,
non-invasive test. It can detect
colorectal cancer very well, but the sensitivity drops a
lot for the advanced adenomas. So we
started looking for another blood-based
test,
that doesn't rely on the tumor direct shedding, and
make
better for early detection.
That led us to the red blood cells, the most
abundant cells in blood.
They're generally considered to have no nucleus, but DNA
remnants such as Howell-Jolly bodies have been observed
for over a century, and
during the red blood cell development,
the nucleus are normally expelled.
But when DNA damage occurs,
DNA remnants were separated from the
main nucleus and persist in the mature
red blood cells.
For decades,
counting the red blood cells with DNA remnants have been
a standard method for in vivo genotoxicity
testing and widely used in drug development and
environmental monitoring. But today, we can sequence them.
Emerging evidence shows that red blood cell-associated RBC
DNA could reflect the genomic instability,
and in our previous study, we have shown that
a solid tumor could remotely regulate the bone marrow
hematopoiesis and generate the DNA remnants in red
blood cells that we simply call the RBC DNA.
And our previous data show the RBC DNA has a
potential in early cancer detection.
Here is our workflow for purifying red blood cells
and extracting RBC DNA, and then we perform the low
coverage sequencing.
We found the RBC DNA has distinctive physiological
characteristics.
Compared with genomic DNA, RBC DNA are much shorter
with an average of 4.3
kilobases. At the same time, they are much longer
than typical cell-free DNA fragments.
When we compare the genomic profiles of RBC DNA
and
leukocyte genomic DNA from healthy donors, we found,
as shown here, RBC DNA
has
a distinct rate distribution
across a whole genome, and it has much
lower proportion of rates mapped in
mitochondrial regions.
So we think the RBC DNA
carries unique biological signals.
But the next question is, can this signal
change in cancer?
So we analyzed a small cohort of colorectal cancer
patients and healthy donors.
And we found the normalized rate
count
at a specific genomic regions was different between
the two groups.
Across a
full set of colorectal cancer-associated red
blood cell DNA features, we found
we can
separate the colorectal cancer patients
from the healthy donors in this clustering.And
our results suggest
colorectal cancer may leave a detectable
signature in red blood cell DNA
profile.
But whether the tumor-associated red blood cell
signal
is
useful. So we evaluated
in another advanced
colorectal neoplasia cohort. In this cohort, we
enrolled 1,251 treatment-naive
participants, including controls without
advanced neoplasia, and the patients with advanced
adenomas and colorectal patients.
Because we focused on the early detection, so in this
cohort, we
made nearly half of the cases with advanced
adenomas.
Then we
randomly split the cohort into discovery site
and the internal tester site.
In the discovery site, we identify the
disease-associated red blood cell features, and then
we
development a binary
model. Then we
evaluated the performance in the internal test site.
As shown here, our model achieved an overall AUC
of 95% for detecting advanced
colorectal neoplasia.
And
90 specificity, the model achieved
85 sensitivity for advanced adenomas
and 95 sensitivity for colorectal cancer.
And our model performance remained
consistent from the pre-cancerous lesions and
the late-stage cancers.
But the internal result was
promising, but the real test is independent validation.
So we evaluated the locked
model in two independent cohort from different
cities in China.
And
our data shows
from both external
cohort maintains a high specificity and
sensitivity for colorectal cancer.
And we found the sensitivity for advanced adenomas
was dropped slightly, but it
stayed over 60%.
And our
performance was not affected by baseline characteristics,
lifestyle factors, and the blood cell counts.
So we think the RBC-DNA
signals is not
mainly rely on the common confounders.
And then we
evaluated
RBC-DNA
in a prospective clinical cohort.
And in this cohort, we had performed a head-to-head
comparison with stool-based fecal immunochemical
test, and we enrolled
585 participants with available
RBC-DNA and stool-based test results.
In this cohort, we found
comparable specificity in controls and
high sensitivity in colorectal cancers.
And importantly, we found
for advanced adenomas and Stage 1 colorectal cancer,
the sensitivity was much higher than the
stool-based test.
So this
study clearly
suggests us the potential
of RBC-DNA in
pre-cancerous lesions.
So in summary, we have developed a
sequence-based workflow for purifying
RBC-DNA as one to two milliliter of blood.
And we identify the RBC-DNA features
associated with advanced colorectal neoplasia.
And we conducted a model
that could
better detect early-stage colorectal cancer and
advanced adenomas. And our previous
study also shows that RBC-DNA reflects tumor-induced
changes in bone marrow hematopoiesis, and it's not
rely on the tumor
shading.
So it's also the potential for the early detection.
And I'd like to acknowledge my lab and
collaborators and all participate patients.
Thanks for your attention.
Thank you very much. This abstract is open for discussion,
comments.
Can I start with some simple thing?
Beautiful data, but can you speculate where is this
RBC-DNA coming from? How sure you are that it is coming from the
tumor cells, not some systemic inflammation in the colon,
something else?
Okay.
In our previous published data, we have shown
therbcDNA is not from the tumor
cells, and it's from the bone marrow
hematopoiesis, just like the-
Sorry, I should rephrase my questions. I didn't mean coming from the tumor.
I mean, reflecting tumor
genomics. Somehow it has to account for
carcinogenesis in the body, right? But this is rbcdna.
Yeah.
Okay.
Is it tumor specific-
Is it tumor specific or is it-
Or can you have inflammatory syndrome?
Oh, okay.
We think it's tumor specific,
because we have involved
many kinds of controls.
So what happens if a patient has, for example, gastric cancer or
pancreas cancer? Would you see the specificity for colon versus
other GI cancers?
Yes. In this study, we have found the
colorectal
cancer specific rbcdna features.
And in our previous study, we have found the pan-cancer
associated rbcdna study. And
this genomic feature is not a
common feature.
Thank you.
Two questions.
Great talk. Really interesting. I think my question is actually very similar, and
so feel free to just punt it, so I'm kind of repeating.
But can you just elaborate on what this DNA is?
What are the sequences?
I understand that it associates with the presence of cancer, but
have you looked at what these DNA sequences are?
What
portion of the genome? How does it relate to the cancer?
We have
validated this data in the mouse model.
And in this mouse model, we
use the Apc mutant
mouse model
and the
cell roast data to
validate these tumor-associated features
is
generated from the
systematic signaling in
the
hematopoiesis cells.
Interesting. Yeah. Please.
Hey, thanks. Great talk. Victor Chubuk from Freedom.
I'm curious, there's a pretty well-established association between anemia and
colorectal cancer. Do you think that is related at all to your findings?
Anemia in-
Anemia.
In colon cancer? Is that driving the association?
Okay.
Low hemoglobin.
In this study,
we didn't have the data in
the blood disease, and we will do this.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Yeah. Great idea.
Very interesting talk and very impressive data.
I'm just curious about for the advanced adenoma, there are many
subtypes, and many are driven by different
pathways or different mutations.
Did you see any difference in terms of the performance?
And whether it's associated with APC, KRAS, or some other
mutations?
In our previous data, we
found the
IL-18
was secreted from the colorectal tumors
and remotely regulated the bone marrow hematopoiesis.
And in this data, this colorectal cancer
specific rbcdna features. And we also found the
IL-20 was enriched in IL-22 pathways,
and...
Yeah, maybe if I can ask a follow-up question.
So,
yeah, very short. So did you see also elevated
positivity rates on the non-advanced adenoma?
Adenoma?
Yeah, because you detected the one adenoma that's also even earlier
stage that's not-
Oh, okay
... adenoma, that's considered benign. But yeah.
Oh, okay.
In this study, the
adenoma, we saw the advanced
features as in our control group, and we
didn't see
the tumor-associated features have the
similar
rate counts in these
patients.
It's
not similar compared with
advanced adenomas.
Last burning question.
Similar question about the biology of the signal. So colorectal.
Great. Okay, you see the signal. If you look at other tumors, do you see
similar observation? Again, I'm struggling to understand how the biology of our
rbcdna is connected to colorectal cancer.
Yes.
In our previous data, we have showed the pan-cancer data and
gastric cancer or
lung cancer.
And are there genomic characteristic that you observe
in the sequencing? What are those?
Are they similar? Does the genetic
signal tells you anything about-
No
...
the biological relationship?
No.
We found the
tumor specific rbcdna features
are not very common features.
But they have some common regions
Thank you.
This might be a good lead to the next talk.
The sites on the RBC-
He's asking a question.
Yeah. The sites on the RBCs that you pick up,
are they related to anything with methylation?
Oh, we didn't have the methylation data on-
No, those sites, do they target any genes that are involved in methylation?
Histone methylation, DNA methylation.
Because I'm wondering if what you're seeing is a correlation between a methylation
signature.
We don't have this data right now.
No, the sites that you have on the RBCs.
Yes. Oh.
Those DNA sites, what genes are they targeting?
On the
previous slides,
we compared with the RBC DNA and the genomic DNA,
and in these slides, we have found
some enriched region in RBC DNA, and
this region was
enriched in
blood cells,
was enriched in the
transcription actives in blood cells.
Thanks. Great. That'll be interesting to look at the epigenetic
context of those regions further.
So let's
wrap it up there. Thank you.
All right.
Great discussion. So our last speaker is Yupeng
He from Guardant Health, who will be speaking about a
methylation-based molecular tumor typing
classifier for tissue samples from cancers of
unknown primary.
Thank you. Thank you for the introduction
and the opportunity to
present the work of my team did in
Guardant Health.
This work was led by Amira, the first person listed in the author list.
And the challenges we try to address is to predict the tissue
of origin using methylation data for
patients whose cancer primary sites is
unknown. So it's usually called as cancer of unknown primary or
CUP.
So here's my disclosure.
So CUP cases usually represents metastatic
malignancy, with no detectable
primary sites. They usually represents 1 to 3% of
the cancer cases. So clearly, there's a
mandate, as you can tell from the name, the tissue of origin
is missing and a lot of the treatments are based on the tissue,
especially
treatment guidelines are based on the tissue of origin.
So
this is definitely a need, and the conventional method to
address this is histopathology and also
immunostaining.
Usually, they
cannot
lead to a conclusive resolution of the cases.
So
this usually leads to delay in treatment and a
poor treatment efficacy. So the
solution we are
trying to provide is to use molecular evidence
and to supplement the convention diagnostic approach.
And this approach we are going to develop needs to be shown,
and for it to be useful for
CUP cases adjudication, it has to be robust against
a range of tumor fraction, and
you could also work regardless of the biopsy sites, because in CUP cases,
biopsy sites doesn't all usually equivalent to primary sites.
And we want it to work on FFPE
tissue samples, especially for the ones with low tumor purity,
which is super common in CUP cases as well.
The biomarker we are using to address this challenge is DNA methylation.
So it's known as a regulatory
mechanism for gene expression and also cell identity.
And DNA methylation, including two forms,
hypermethylation and hypomethylation, are both hallmarks
of cancer.
And in general, the DNA methylation
preserve the cell identity and tissue identity information,
which is the foundation of our method.
So if you look at the heat map, it shows
the methylation level of more than a thousand DMRs or
differentially methylated regions, where you could see that the
methylation pattern is different for different tissue.
As I mentioned above, this is the foundation of the method.
And people has been using methylation to resolve
the diagnosis of CUP cases, and feasibility has
already been demonstrated.
So our methods rely on GR360 tissue
testing platform, which is a multi-omics
test for advanced solid tumor.
And it analyze both DNA sequence, DNA methylation,
and also RNA expression.
It analyze more than 20,000 differentially methylated
regions, so we can leverage the
methylation profile of those regions to resolve the tissue of
origin.
Two interesting
or two important requirements for this tissue testing,
and it require only 5% minimal
tumor fraction, which is much lower than a typical
20% requirement for commercial tissue testing, and it only require
very low surface area. So this allow us to apply
to more
CUP tissue samples.And the methods
we developed is called molecular tumor typing or
molecular tumor type, or MTT classifier.
It was trained on more than 6,000 FFPE
tissue samples of normal tissue
from normal individual and also from
cancer patients of 24 cancer types.
And it reports the prediction for those 24 cancer types with
the confidence level.
So here's a overview of the algorithm.
So we have 24 models. So we take this
one versus all training strategy,
and we use the 24 models, which
each was trained to score one cancer type.
And for new test samples, we will have score from each of the models.
So
based on the 24 scores,
MTT classifier determine the evaluability and also the
confidence level. So for the evaluable samples, we
usually report either one or two
predictions
along with the confidence level.
We first evaluate these methods on more than 4,000
samples. Those were not seen during model
development. And those samples have known diagnosis,
so we know at least these methods could work on samples we have
the ground truths. So on this 4,000 tissue
samples, we observe 97% of them
to be evaluable.
And the accuracy is 91% with just the primary
prediction and 93% with the top two
predictions.
As I mentioned before, for this to be useful for
CAPP use case, the
performance of this method has to be robust across a wide range of tumor
fraction, and we did see that on this
cohort.
And notably, 24% of the samples evaluated has
tumor fraction less than 20%. And
MTT classifier maintained a high performance on this
small subset. And those tissue samples usually will
get rejected for tissue testing because
of the low tumor fraction. But with our methods, we are able to recover them and
provide accurate prediction.
And we also want to evaluate whether this test is
able, or this classifier is able to
predict a primary site of the tumor
even when the
tissue samples were collected from some other
metastatic site and a low tumor fraction.
So
to evaluate this, we use
slightly less than 700 samples collected from liver
and lung tissue,
with less than 30% tumor fraction.
And on this set, there are two cohorts.
One is where the primary sites match the
collection site or organ site, and there's also another cohort
called primary cancer, where the collection sites match the primary site.
So in both cases, the performance of the
MTT classifier remain high
and suggesting that we could actually apply these methods to CAPP
cases with no unknown primary, because there's no
guarantee that the collection sites will be the same as the primary site.
And we did apply it to
slightly more than 500 CAPP
cases
we have from commercial orders. And we found that around
85% of them are evaluable, and we were
able to have
high confidence primary prediction in around 80% of them.
And on the primary predictions, we found that
biliary, lung adenocarcinoma, and colorectal are the
common prediction,
or the predicted cancer types matching what's reported in
literature.
And among of them, there are 34 where we
have a suspected diagnosis based
on pathology
data, so we could compare the prediction against for further
evaluation.
So among those 34
cases, we have results for 33 of them,
and prediction accuracy is 88%, so we
get it right on 29 out of 33 and be wrong on
four of them,
if we used
only the primary prediction, and we recover one if
we include both the primary and secondary prediction.
And that's also a breakdown between high confidence prediction and
low confidence prediction, and can see that the confidence level is
trending well with the
accuracy of this classifier.
We then did a deep dive into the four
cases where
at least the primary prediction does not match the suspected
diagnosis.
And we were able to identify confounders actually in all
cases. So on the first case,
the confounder seems to be due to the
squamous cell carcinoma origin
of these CAPP samplesWhen
the prediction predicted as an anogenital squamous cell
carcinoma, actually it's identified as head neck squamous
cell carcinoma, and the second prediction captured that.
For the
second and third cases, there are
molecular evidence and so pathology evidence pointing to multiple
possible primary,
and actually, our classifier is able to
match one of them. It's not just not the first
suspect
from the pathology.
On the fourth cases, the last cases,
the prediction has median confidence level, suggesting that there
is some uncertainty in the molecular data is well captured by the confidence
level.
Just to summarize, I hope you are convinced that we
developed methods that could work at a very high
accuracy across a wide range of tumor fraction,
as well as from different biopsy sites, which could
be used for CAP cases adjudication
using tissue data.
And I think the most thing I want to highlight here is
that the methods we developed,
it's a good supplement
to the CAP adjudication practice.
And I think integrating all the evidence we could get is
still the critical thing to do to list to a better
patient care.
I will stop here and happy to take any questions.
Thank you. We have time for questions. Yes.
Hi. Thank you, Yuhong, for your amazing talk.
I wonder if you ever plan or you're able to detect any
specific cancer subtypes or mutations
from methylation because I think it's supposed to able to see that.
Yeah, that's a great question. I think like in this classifier,
we emphasize on identifying the most like a tissue or
organ level
adjudication. But yes, it's possible to say,
predict the subtypes of lung cases or breast cases with
methylation and genomic data, for sure.
Thank you.
Please.
Hi. My question refers to the CAPs where you had
a particularly hard time to assign an
presumed
organ of origin. Did those samples have
special common features like embryonic developmental
features?
Not that we were aware. We were not able to identify any
specific things that would predict whether they are easy to be
resolvable.
So no commonalities among those you couldn't assign?
There could be, but we didn't find any.
Hi. Great talk. So I have several questions.
So the first one is, you mentioned about you are using
about over 20,000
DMR, and I noticed for some specific cancer type, it seems the prediction
pretty low. So have you had a chance to look at that one, why it's pretty
low? Is there any possibility that for some DMRs, maybe it's specific
to cancer type?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think there are
some similarities between different cancer types.
So if you're thinking about cancer-specific DMRs for those,
and you only want to find the regions that have hyper or
hypo-methylation specific to that cancer type will be challenging.
But I think that the quantitative difference in terms of methylation
between different cancer types are also pretty informative.
So you can actually aggregate the data from multiple DMRs to
make accurate prediction.
Yeah. Thank you. Another question I have is,
have you ever think about integrating with multi-omics, for example?
I know, let's say for the CAP, there is maybe consider,
let's say, DGs, differential methylation genes or maybe other method to improve the
overall performance.
Yeah, that's a great question. I think integrating methylation and
also genomic mutation, especially RNA expression, is definitely the way to go.
So we are just first step here. And
probably say a little bit more about the
complementarity of methylation and also gene
expression, because gene expression represents more like a
life state of the cell, while methylation, it's more about the
identity of the cell. So if you want to get to a more granular
resolution of the tissue of origin, I think expression is definitely
required.
Yeah. Sorry. Last question is, I noticed the cancer CAP
has some imbalance issues. I mean, I wouldn't call it issue, but
I noticed that the cancer CAP is actually a little imbalanced.
So have you considered that part when you are building the model?
Yeah. We definitely consider that we don't
want
the imbalance in the training sets to bias the model training.
Yeah, we definitely use some techniques to balance that.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hi. Great talk. I was curious, are there shared
top features in your model, like shared regions of methylation that are the most
important across cancer types?
Yeah, definitely.
There are 24, but
I'll say it's hard to comment one by one.
But especially for the cancer types with shared biology,
there's a lot of shared features, for sure.
Hi. Great talk. I was wondering, the DMRs that you
see for the carcinoma of unknown primary,
you look at advanced cancers, but are those still applicable
or fundamental if you were to look at early cancers?
Yeah. That's a great question. Probably want to add that
although I present the tissue data, we actually have something similar
on
liquid biopsy product as well. And we found that this
type of approach is generally applicable to both tissue
liquid biopsy data or cell-free DNA data, as well as on
early-stage cancer. Yes.
And the tissue signatures are as-
Yes, at least on our data, they are largely preserved.
Thank you.
All stages. Yes.
I have one small query. How do you see this assay
getting integrated into current clinical diagnostic
workflow for
ambiguous cases or where IHC or some other
approaches were not definitive?
Yeah, I think
for a patient to be categorized as CAB, usually you cannot resolve it with
the conventional approach. I think this will provide additional evidence
to support
maybe some of the suspected directions or some of the suspected
cancer types. And it's also possible they disagree with all of
them. So I think we'll need the clinicians, and we get more data
to really understand how to use this type of information.
Thank you.
Since you mentioned liquid biopsy at the end there, and it is a liquid biopsy
session,
how low can you go in term-- Can you go below 5%?
Can this be applied in localized or early detection setting?
So we could definitely go below 5% because, in
liquid biopsy data, usually you have tumor fraction much
lower than that. But you definitely need...
I think for early cancer detection will be a challenge, but usually people only
apply this type of technology on the cases where you could detect
any ctDNA. So the bar is not as low as
you alluded to. So it's definitely
workable, and the performance is expected to be worse on the lower tumor fraction,
but at some point it still work pretty well.
Looking forward to that.
Thank you.